Now that we've learned from users, we're going to iterate our designs, and
then we'll commit to them. And we're going to wrap them up in
a presentation. Before we do that, let's go check in with the
students at Udacity office, and hear what they've learned from this project.
>> I wanted to feel good when I use this
up. So say someone came on or within your range. But
what if you see a flower or a fun picture that
you like. Hmm; Hmmm. It adds a click, but it makes
me feel good and I'm happy to compensate for a click,
as far as it makes me feel good. So you click
on that and then it shows you the map and shows
you the person that you're most likely to barter with or
exchange or transact with, and gives a little profile of who
they are and What they're wanting to offer. Once you dig
deeper there's a screen that tells you how many hours you
have. So these were just supposed to be coins that you
have 16 hours right now and for this transaction you need three
hours. There's a little button that can help you transact, and once you
have transacted makes you feel better by showing you an ice cream
cone or a heart sign, or some image that makes you feel nice.
>> I like the fact that you're putting a focus on that one person.
So if that's like a mutual thing, like if you got shown Clifton's profile, and
then Clifton gets showed Kanall's profile, you
establish that mutual connection. It's much more kind
of deep and meaningful than just seeing like
a list right? And you pick from list.
>> Yeah because it seemed to me as if the, the soul of the business.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Was about exchanging hours and not
money. And that was, it was already fun.
>> I like the flower idea, I would've taken that from you,
if you don't already have it on camera, the thought of it.
>> You should take it.
>> It's okay.